你的爸妈能对你产生的作用，
不外乎道德，
无外乎亲情的绑架，
无外乎让你感恩，
我可以感恩啊，
你们养我花了多少钱，
我可以还给你们，
在我经济条件允许的时候，
我可以一点一点还给你们。
但是我的婚姻，
天王老子来了也是我做主，
天王老子来了也是我说了算，
谁来不好使，
我家里是和肥公司的，
因为我这个兄弟姐妹，
我自己一个人是出来上学的，
现在父亲是在北京，
我在学校里的时候谈了一个对象，
我家里就不是很同意，
但是现在我也跟我对象在一块儿3年了，
前些天吧，
有一个亲戚刚跟我妈说了啊，
你说我不同意也不行，
我妈就说了，
那就结婚吧，
现在卡在彩礼这儿了，
因为我们那边要的彩礼是比较多的，
你要多少啊，
至少20万，
新婚前定算万，
可能就是5~8万这样子，
要再加三金，
但是我们家是没有什么嫁妆的，
虽然我现在我对象他就不是很乐意，
而且我们那边的彩礼基本上都是要交给家里的，
不是放在我自己这边，
我对象他只愿意给20多的一些，
加起来回家三金。
其实我跟我对象的感情很好，
在我家那边的眼里看来，
这个男的一定得是愿意出钱才是真的对你好。
我觉得我对象人挺好的，
他的工作也很好，
而且他自己也比较上进，
所以我不是那么想要逼迫我对象拿出这么多钱来。
你爸妈这个做法是完全把你往火坑里推，
拿了人家20万的彩礼，
不给陪嫁，
这个完全是把你往火坑里面推，
如果真这么干的话，
你们两口子过不好，
因为他会像一根刺一样梗在你们两口子之间，
你现在选一头，
要么得罪爸妈，
要么得罪你的这个对象，
你选一头，
我跟我家里其实处起来关系也不是很好，
这是我第二个对象，
我第一个谈着，
也是因为我家里不同意分手的。
那如果是这种情况的话，
你爸妈在你身上投入的，
比如说供你读书啊，
上学啊，
花了多少钱，
你以后工作了，
那一点一点的也就回馈给家里头了，
自己就硬气了。
所以说人生婚姻大事的话，
自己做主，
你是受过高等教育的，
而且你在一线城市，
你的思想已经是拥有这种潜质的，
能独立的可能性的，
本来你跟你爸妈也不在同一个城市，
亲戚啊，
朋友啊，
社会关系啊也不在一块儿，
所以这事儿就是你自己为你的人生负责任。
你爸妈的这个做法显然是把你往火坑里面推，
但是我们家的意见是，
如果我不把彩礼钱如果他们守的话，
他们就不会去我的婚礼上，
那又怎样呢？
婚礼不一定要办啊，
但是我觉得这样会不会被男方家里看不起，
男方家里能不能看得起你，
取决于你有什么本事，
取决于你将来能有什么作用，
取决于你的能力怎么样，
你能为他们提供什么，
你将来比如说教育资源，
你自己的工作能力，
你的社会关系能不能给男方提供。
处理不取决于你爸妈是干什么的，
和我就给我家里态度强，
留意点什么，
没必要撕破脸。
我希望我直播间的所有女孩子要明白一个法律，
你满了18周岁，
你的人生的所有的角色，
你自己都可以做主了，
你要上哪个大学，
你要去哪儿工作，
你要在哪个城市生活，
你要干什么，
满了18岁，
你自己都可以做主，
只要你满了20周岁，
你的婚姻你就可以自己做主了，
你想嫁给谁，
你不想嫁给谁，
你想离异，
你想就再婚啊，
这都是你自己能做主的事情。
你的爸妈能对你产生的作用，
无外乎道德，
无外乎亲情的绑架，
无外乎让你感恩，
我可以感恩啊，
你们养我花了多少钱，
我可以还给你们，
在我经济条件允许的时候，
我可以一点一点还给你们，
但是我的婚姻，
天王老子来了也是我做主，
天王老子来了也是我说了算，
谁来不好使，
哼，
我一直以来总算比较听话了，
因为我爸妈也比较辛苦，
所以我现在可能经常的就会比较懦弱。
男方是干什么的呀？
这是国企，
北京国企那也挺好的呀，
他愿意给20万直接打你卡里，
这事可千万别退步啊，
别到时候又让步了，
直接打你卡里啊。
至以说要不要什么三金不重要，
哪怕你花二十几块钱，
三十几块钱在淘宝上买一些像黄金的东西，
结婚的时候带一带都可以，
三金什么的没有那么重要，
但是20万很重要，
我家里看要这个钱的露的，
因为你还有弟弟吗我。
是有，
但是他们也说怕我自己拿着，
到时候男方家里可能会买车买房，
会用什么的，
那就取决于你自己了。
今天龙飞姐就告诉你，
这20万是你的保命钱，
是你和孩子将来的保命钱，
谁来都不好使，
谁管我借没有不借，
你爸妈说怕什么什么是怎么地的，
可笑不可笑，
司马昭之心路人皆知其是，
我心里也知道这个在看钱保我都有一丝幻想，
我们和父母的关系，
在我有能力的情况下，
如果我觉得父母是图我身上的钱，
图我这个图我那个的话，
我也能坦然的接受，
在我有能力的情况下，
我可以回报你们。
但是彩礼这个事情，
如果让男方从一开始就喉咙里梗着这根刺儿过日子的话，
这个日子你就不好过了，
很多父母就看不清这一点，
我跟你说，
像你男朋友，
他是国企的，
可能还稍微好一点，
像如这种农村的啊，
如果说给了20万的彩礼，
然后女方又不给嫁妆，
这20万的彩礼落到了女方父母身上的话，
那这男方就会往死了用这个女的，
就相当于我这20万买了你了，
让你做饭怎么了？
让你打扫卫生怎么了？
我都花了20万，
让你给我生孩子怎了？
让你给我生二胎怎么了？
我都花20万，
头婆也会往死了欺负你，
我都花了20万没错吧，
你在婆家的生活开局就很难过了，
这20万呢？
就您说这20万就是保命钱，
就是我和我将来的孩子能够保住命的钱，
谁来都不好使，
谁敢问我借的不？
使，
然后公公来接，
婆婆来接，
不好使，
谁来都不好使，
然后的好，
那就这样啊，
奶奶，
嗯，
其实我们现实生活中像这样的女孩子很多，
一方面想知道父母有没有爱我，
另一方面父母有没有那么坏，
他没有到那种真的是像卖女儿那种境地啊，
把你卖给瘸子，
把你卖给瞎子，
把你卖给什么50岁的老头儿啊，
50岁人家也未必是老头啊。
打个比方，
他没有坏到那种程度，
他对你呢，
有爱吗？
他也关心你啊，
他也心疼你，
吃的饱不饱啊，
穿的暖不暖啊，
他也心疼你，
有没有受人欺负呀？
但是父母观念很陈旧，
就觉得我不能白养你一场，
好多父母是不是这种想法，
我不能白养你？
一听到这个话我就很生气，
这是什么糟粕思想？
你这个话的潜台词是什么？
你养我是为了赚钱了，
你养我是为了投资收益了，
你养我是为了你自己养老了，
不能白养我一场什么逻辑？
记得点赞关注。